have you been beaten up raped all that
stuff I've been raped so many times that
has become acceptable I think that laws
like I got out of it oh it's okay I
didn't cry it's okay
you heard me that time it's okay all
right
amber yes amber where'd you grow up were
you from I'm from Los Angeles California
and I grew up on the west side of Los
Angeles like well they could pick in
LaBrea area you're working Figueroa
Street
yeah apparently working on Figueroa
Street I'm a working girl you know I
work in the hundreds so that would be
from like 100 this first Street all the
way down to like like a 700 so it goes
as far as London 50th Street oh yeah
that's my work right and tell me about
your childhood yet both your parents
growing up yeah I grew up with a mother
and father in the house really good
living at first everything was great you
know it's Catholic school has the best
toys best friends and whatever like that
then my dad died he was murdered where
did you I was 12 years old I'm sorry oh
thank you
so when my dad died everything just
changed dramatically dramatically went
from having a you know --kavitha school
to having no school
my mom's start using drugs and she was
mourning my dad the loss of my dad is
their only man Owen milf she'd ever had
so she took that really hard she she got
depressed very depressed
and she went on at that same time rock
cocaine was just hitting senior ella
well you know heavy and she got part of
that she became a part of that scene
well your family take the hit really
hard yeah my first whole family took the
hit but every one of my family used
drugs but my mom's her dragon or abuse
was the worst of all the siblings any
kids of course suffering yeah of course
kids suffering yeah chuckling yeah we
ever the younger sister she's 7 years
younger than me I don't know if I could
see her name so I'll just say she's my
younger sister yeah now I was a
sacrifice everything for her everything
do you help support the
the families well what-what happened is
my mom you know she's start using drugs
and they have these things called crack
houses rock houses yeah it's where you
go in there you buy your stuff and you
get stale they're all all day all night
so you couldn't stay any longer and um
she's do that so I first started off
like she would leave like $800 in a note
pay this bill pay that bill and get this
get that and I went from $800 um she'd
be gone maybe two days it was from that
to be gone like leaving no money no
lights no gas and no no and I I had to
take care of my six-year-old sister so I
sacrificed my everything for her till
you started working the street at what
age I first start working at first day
my first trick I like around 16 but I
start working the streets heavily I have
my 18 when I became an adult yeah yeah
you can turn to face me if you want
oh yeah and so do you work with a pimp
or without a pimp oh I've know of him I
have a pimp it's my drug addiction is my
again you know that's all that all that
pimp I need yeah my pipe a lighter that
motivates you that'sthat's it gets me up
in the morning please me down yeah I
don't I don't follow directions too well
so a pimp wouldn't be a good thing for
me yeah and then crack is your drug
right now yeah but I used tracks other
words hey whatever scene I'm a knife it
with that scene if I put some Heather
you know whatever drug I want to please
so I please whatever whoever so I have
that means I'll blend in with your scene
you know
did you see other friends of yours at
that there's a teenager that we're doing
this for a living and that's where you
got the idea
no I had one friend owed her friends she
was a couple years older than me she was
on drugs at that time I wasn't using
when I was younger younger she had a
friendly to you
young bro and I was 16 and in need of
money you know parents on drugs I'll
straight out
nothing at home you know no food got a
little sister look out for it
I do what I need to do at the time
that's how I looked at it did your
family know you were doing this no they
they if they know it's only because
they've seen me outside
they've never like I've never come out
to my family to this to this day it's
his day so they might see this video
yeah they probably a lot of people
viruses video it's almost like a way of
confessing for a lot of people I think
yeah it's a confession but it's also
like freeing like lifting cuz like I've
always wanted my story be told cuz I
have one like other young ladies or
young man up there to know if they have
a similar story that you know this is
what can happen to you if you know don't
its her left you keep going right don't
your laugh yeah it's gonna happen to you
but also just the the knowing that you
know [ __ ] happens to people you know I
never wants volunteer to be a drug
addict or and everyone said when I
graduated high school I'm gonna be on
drugs or I'm gonna be a hooker
never I'm gonna have the rape the
regular goes you know lawyer this is
lawyer doctor the things that normal
kids you know what it's probably you had
those dreams oh yeah I still have those
dreams I stopped college days I go
school right now told you
I'm 45 you're 45 yeah you look great
Thanks yeah it's great it's never too
late right I said about Zach we're gonna
let bachelor's degree you took it I
could totally buy you as a lawyer yeah I
just like people I just wanna help
people so me I would help I want to I
want to be I hope that know it was
really a fair about me I want to help
you know I got some kids out there in
foster care and they might need my help
one day I'll not even know that's me cuz
I don't know my children so it's some
division of life that I come across in I
make a change in some things you never
know they might come to Amber's house
and that's just my organization you know
no good for ya there was a lot I hope
when I was younger yeah I think it's
times have changed a bit yeah it's a
good thing time to change out times
adapt it did you like can you help the
kids soon did you find it have you been
arrested for this oh I've been arrested
twice for the
Oh CJ I'm sorry three times first time I
was 18 second third time it was better
like in the last five years but yeah I'm
probably classified as a prostitute cuz
I know why that Grimes you know later
yeah I've been arrested for this three
times does it get you down sometimes
he's a pro do you get depressed
oh yeah it's lifestyle difference every
day yeah I mean what was me you know
sucks to be me but they're depressed
every day I deal with that it's long
with the fact that I already deal with
that issue in my life I'm in a health
issue it doesn't help that you know I
haven't I'm out there on the streets
mm-hmm cuz I get I got my moments every
day where I'm like damn you know but
then I take that hit and I remember why
I live there yes but despite the way you
look you dress beautifully and you you
don't look like you're working the
streets well thank you yeah you're
thinking more pop you look like a
professional HIV know I just wonder yeah
I always think like you never know how
family might see me walking down the
street I want to these same is she
working but she not working I want you
to guess it you know if I am because of
what time I saw my son's father drive
down paths Street and I was just like a
Hollywood Happy Hooker from the
seventies you know anything everything's
short little and the look he gave me was
like with such disgust that it was like
okay you can do this but you don't got
to look like the robot like what the
stereotypical yeah you don't look like
the other girls the her oh yeah what you
can't look like it's very obvious with a
thank you
right where's with you I feel like no
baby she's right I've had that happen to
me are you working the bird you sure you
know but yeah I do
do you feel like this life has changed
you you've been doing it for a long time
yeah how was it changed it's made me a
little
harder like I mean I was very gullible
as a child you know I know
gobo and and believed you I believe
whether you tell me I always believe the
liars but being out here it's I've
learned how to like that decipher it's
the truth from a lie or just take my own
risk with things I definitely have
become like harder like if I care I do
care so I can't take that out of away
from me and that gets me into a lot of
trouble sometimes you know because I'm
not that fierce and I don't give a damn
kind of woman I worry about like
sometimes to do things and I my
conscience kicks in right immediately
you know sometimes the two things that
karma it's in before I getting to sit
down again so I recognize those things
us I like that I like that I can still
look in the mirror and I still know
between right and wrong because I'm
worried that if I stay out here so much
longer I'm gonna be like those my
friends or those associates I know that
are just like I'll cut your throat
before you put your eye and I'll take
everything you got and I don't care if
you're is this whatever it falls to you
I mean it I want it I'm getting it yeah
I've interviewed some of your some of
those providers nothing like that yeah
but what's the most misunderstood thing
about girls that are working for the
streets like this that they're just
always like don't they're out just
always like a lot of women out here have
suffering from severe trauma severe and
they start using drugs and support that
habit they don't want to rob you I don't
rob you I don't steal your stuff I don't
want to go to prison again say I've done
prison term
I don't know the prison again so I had
to figure out what am I in do support my
habit this time and the walked I met a
street called Figueroa I never knew what
it was so I accidently won't start
walking down that Street
but yeah the biggest misconception is
that we have feelings too
we still count you know don't you see
that man beating up that girl you know
just pull over and say hey care a little
bit yeah have you been beaten up raped
all this way this is really weird
so I've been assaulted so many times and
it's just I look at it as part of the
job you might get paid he might not get
paid
I've been raped so many times that has
become acceptable I think that laws like
I got out of it oh it's okay I didn't
cry it's okay
you heard me that time it's okay so yeah
yeah changes what your line being across
it oh it's just each time you're
assaulted just sticks out leave whatever
a little bit instance you have it in you
it takes it the chips away at it well
like I said you look at it like it's
part of the job sometimes you get paid
sometimes you don't have you been in
love before
uh-huh every day no Richard I'm Julia
Roberts and I was looking for Richard
Gere
so yes I'm always in love really I
always have a boyfriend always did you
KITT f4 and do you raise them no my
oldest he's 13 now when I walked away
from him he was three and a half the
other three I've had on the streets so I
have a pair of twins and they're eight
in my last maybe he's five who's raising
him the system anybody but whatever
fashion that is my twins were born with
cerebral palsy so being on the streets I
knew from the beginning that when they
were born was their issue so I was gonna
be able take care of them you know if I
should wait so my addiction and twins
and they're both having special needs so
I made a big decision that did not fight
the system
yeah that's when you say they're born on
the streets meaning the father it was
one of your customers no well yeah no no
not really
I said so jobs have a boyfriend yeah
your father was a boyfriend got it but
what I did mean I was just is that that
was writing it the whole time on the
streets yeah so not a good environment
for not getting virus eaters not in your
environment to have a baby you know not
everybody's you pregnant every day there
your story's interesting because you're
your childhood was great until your dad
passed away yeah
and anything change it's a very
different story than a lot of those days
I've talked to me well amber thank you
so much for sharing your story okay good
luck with uh with law school or wherever
you go for you okay thank you my tobe by
yours away thank you thank you so much
thank you thank you
you